This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the mid-1980s, Coca-Cola was feeling threatened by the growing popularity of its rival, Pepsi. Executives at Coca-Cola decided to shake things up. In April 1985, they launched a new product. The supermarket shelves throughout America will have the new Coke by Memorial Day weekend, summer's kickoff, and the soft drink season. New Coke promised to be sweeter and smoother. Rounder, yet bolder, is a more harmonious flavor.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。20世纪80年代中期，可口可乐公司感受到了竞争对手百事可乐日益增长的威胁。可口可乐的高管们决定做出改变。1985年4月，他们推出了一款新产品。全美各地的超市货架将在阵亡将士纪念日周末，也就是夏季的开端和软饮料销售旺季到来之前，摆上新可乐。新可乐承诺口感更甜、更顺滑。更圆润，但更浓郁，是一种更和谐的味道。
You're a pretty good copywriter, Roberto. Sounds great, right? But not everyone was happy. Consumers took to the streets to protest New Coke, pouring out the beverage in defiance. The Coca-Cola company received over 40,000 calls and letters from angry, dissatisfied customers. Here's one that starts, dear Chief Dodo, what ignoramus decided to change the formula
你是个很棒的文案，罗伯托。听起来很不错，对吧？但并非所有人都感到高兴。消费者走上街头抗议新可乐，倒掉饮料以示反抗。可口可乐公司收到了超过4万个来自愤怒、不满的客户打来的电话和寄来的信件。其中一封信是这样开头的：亲爱的“多多”总裁，是哪个笨蛋决定更改可乐配方的？
of coke? The new formula is unexciting and it's as bad as Pepsi. Burn it. People didn't just take the change seriously. They took it personally. is unexciting and it's as bad as Pepsi. Burn it." People didn't just take the change seriously. They took it personally. That's un-American because we fought wars to have a choice to have freedom. New Coke was a disaster.
新配方毫无新意，和百事可乐一样糟糕。把它烧了吧。人们不仅仅是认真对待这次改变。他们把它当成了个人问题。这太不美国了，因为我们为了拥有选择权和自由而参加了战争。新可乐是一场灾难。
Customers boycotted it, the media mocked and criticized the move, and distributors were reluctant to sell it. Sales plateaued and a rapid decline loomed on the horizon. The company threw in the towel and switched back to its original formula. Peace and taste buds were restored. There's a saying that's often attributed to Berturt Lantz, a political appointee of former US President Jimmy Carter in the late 1970s. If it ain't broke, don't fix it.
消费者抵制它，媒体嘲笑并批评这一举动，经销商也不愿销售它。销量停滞不前，迅速下滑的阴影笼罩在前方。公司最终认输，换回了原来的配方。平静和味蕾都得到了恢复。有一句常被归因于伯特·兰茨的话，他是美国前总统吉米·卡特在20世纪70年代末任命的政治官员。如果没坏，就别修它。
The origins of this expression go back even further. Farmers believed that when something worked, it was best to leave well enough alone. Tinker with things, and you risk disaster. Today we look at the truth of this old adage. When it makes sense to stay the course and when it makes sense to change direction. This week on Hidden Brain. Imagine you're paddling a boat across a calm lake. The wind is steady, you're moving forward slowly but surely. There's no need to change course, adjust your stroke, or head back to shore. But what if a storm rolls in, or your boat springs a leak, or you feel a sudden stabbing
这个表达的起源甚至可以追溯到更早。农民们认为，当某样东西运作良好时，最好不要去乱动。乱动东西，你就会冒着灾难的风险。今天我们来看看这句古老谚语的真谛。什么时候坚持到底是有意义的，什么时候改变方向是有意义的。本周在《Hidden Brain》。想象一下，你正划着船穿过平静的湖面。风很平稳，你正在缓慢但稳步地前进。没有必要改变航向、调整划桨节奏或返回岸边。但如果暴风雨来袭，或者你的船漏水了，或者你突然感到一阵刺痛
pain in your chest? Now, staying the course and sticking to your plan could be disastrous. At Columbia University, Rita McGrath studies when it makes sense to pivot and when it's wiser to stick with what's worked. Rita McGrath, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be here. Rita, you tell the story of the Gillette Company, a popular personal care brand that most people are familiar with. Give me a brief history of the origins of the company.
胸口疼痛呢？现在，坚持航向和固守计划可能会带来灾难。在哥伦比亚大学，丽塔·麦格拉思研究什么时候转向是有意义的，什么时候坚持已有的成功经验是更明智的。丽塔·麦格拉思，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。很高兴来到这里。丽塔，你讲述了吉列公司的故事，这是一个大多数人都熟悉的个人护理品牌。请简要介绍一下该公司的起源历史。
Sure. So Gillette is one of the most successful consumer product companies in the world. They were founded in 1901, and they were one of the original safety razor manufacturers. So King C. Gillette, the actual man, founded this company. And before that, if you wanted to get a close shave, you pretty much had to go to a barbershop. So it was a huge breakthrough in mass market consumer products. And they were basically able to pull off the strategy unthinkable. They maintained a competitive advantage for literally decades. They were the dominant player. So in 2010, two entrepreneurs, Mark Levine and Michael Dubin,
当然。吉列是世界上最成功的消费品公司之一。他们成立于1901年，是最初的安全剃须刀制造商之一。金·C·吉列，也就是本人，创立了这家公司。在此之前，如果你想刮得干净，你几乎必须去理发店。所以这是大众消费品领域的一个巨大突破。他们基本上实现了不可思议的战略。他们保持了数十年的竞争优势。他们是占据主导地位的参与者。所以到了2010年，两位企业家，马克·莱文和迈克尔·杜宾，
met at a holiday party. Mark was a product wholesaler who had a problem in one of his warehouses. And Michael was a marketer. What was the problem in the warehouse, Rita?? Well Mark has this interesting career where he buys stuff from one part of the world and sells it for a profit in another and as you mentioned he was trying to unload this set of decent quality, not exceptional, but decent quality razors that were made by a South Korean manufacturer. So I understand at this point Mark has something like 250,000 twin razors that were made by a South Korean manufacturer. So I understand at this point, Mark has something like 250,000 twin razors in this warehouse,
在一个节日派对上相遇。马克是一位产品批发商，他的仓库里有一个问题。而迈克尔是一位营销人员。仓库里的问题是什么，丽塔？嗯，马克有一个有趣的职业生涯，他从世界的一个地方买东西，然后以利润卖到另一个地方，正如你提到的，他当时正试图处理掉一批由韩国制造商生产的质量尚可、不算卓越但质量不错的剃须刀。所以我理解在这一点上，马克仓库里有大约25万把双刃剃须刀，
and he approaches Michael, who's an online video marketer, about potentially going into business together. What was the proposal? Well, Mike Dubin at the time was kind of a failed entrepreneur. He found his way into marketing. He was doing a lot of video work. He tried to turn his life around. He applied to the Columbia Business School.
他找到了一位在线视频营销人员迈克尔，商量是否可以一起做生意。提议是什么？嗯，迈克·杜宾当时算是一个失败的企业家。他进入了营销领域。他做了很多视频工作。他试图改变自己的生活。他申请了哥伦比亚商学院。
I'm sad to say we rejected him, which is not so happy. But the two guys get to talking over what I presume is some adult beverages. And what they start thinking about is if you were going to try to sell razors in this day and age, in 2010, you know, we've had e-commerce for a while by then, we've had home delivery of just about everything, why would you do it the way Gillette did it? Gillette's business model was basically you invest in high-end R&D that allows you to charge higher prices for the great products that ensue, and then you use your armies of marketing people to get these things in just the right places in the retail store.
我很遗憾地说我们拒绝了他，这不太令人愉快。但这两个人开始交谈，我推测是在喝了一些成人饮料的情况下。他们开始思考的是，如果你要在当今时代，也就是2010年尝试销售剃须刀，你知道，那时我们已经有电子商务一段时间了，我们已经有了几乎所有东西的送货上门服务，为什么还要像吉列那样做呢？吉列的商业模式基本上是你投资于高端研发，这使你能够为随之而来的优质产品收取更高的价格，然后你利用你的营销大军把这些东西放在零售店里最合适的位置。
And in 1990, when they first introduced the sensor, this was revolutionary. The technology was patented, nobody else could do it. By 2010, when this conversation happens, the world has changed completely. Mark, who had the warehouse of 250,000 South Korean razors, and Michael, the video marketer, asked themselves if they could sell razors over the internet. This could save customers a trip to the store to buy Gillette's higher-priced razors. But the duo also had a brainwave about how to lock in customers long-term. They called it Dollar Shave Club.
而在1990年，当他们首次推出感应式剃须刀时，这是革命性的。这项技术获得了专利，其他人无法做到。到了2010年，当这次谈话发生时，世界已经完全改变了。拥有25万把韩国剃须刀仓库的马克，和视频营销人员迈克尔，问自己是否可以通过互联网销售剃须刀。这可以节省客户去商店购买吉列高价剃须刀的行程。但这对组合还有一个关于如何长期锁定客户的灵感。他们称之为“美元剃须俱乐部”。
Other companies had shown that direct-to-consumer could work, which is a company shipping stuff directly to your door and developing a personal relationship with you. Don't forget, Gillette's main relationships would be like with Walmart, right? They don't actually get all the way to the end customer. And so it gives those DTC, as we call them, companies a big advantage. And he had quite a bit of experience with wholesaling, with retailing, and Dubin knew the power of the internet. So it was that kind of
其他公司已经证明了直接面向消费者（DTC）模式是可行的，即公司直接将产品运送到你家门口并与你建立个人关系。别忘了，吉列的主要关系是与沃尔玛之类的零售商建立的，对吧？他们实际上并没有完全触达最终客户。所以这给了我们所说的DTC公司一个巨大的优势。他有相当多的批发和零售经验，而杜宾知道互联网的力量。所以那是一种
magical moment where the possibilities have really changed. And now you could see a niche in the market where you could actually create something that was entirely new. So the idea was you sell a subscription to people and razors basically show up at your doorstep on a regular basis so you don't have to go to the store you don't have to buy it there's a predictability about it I understand they went to a number of bloggers to try and spread word about it and they started to get people to sign up what was Gillette's initial response to this upstart Rita? They ignored them. Gillette's position now you know you know, as you said in the introduction, if you've had a smooth ship for a long time,
神奇的时刻，可能性真的改变了。现在你可以看到市场上的一个利基点，在那里你可以创造出全新的东西。所以想法是，你向人们出售订阅服务，剃须刀基本上会定期出现在你的家门口，这样你就不必去商店，也不必在那里购买，这具有可预测性。我了解到他们找了一些博主来试图传播这个消息，他们开始让人注册。吉列对这个初创公司的最初反应是什么，丽塔？他们无视了他们。吉列现在的立场，你知道，正如你在介绍中所说，如果你长期以来一直航行平稳，
I mean, if you were an executive at Gillette at that time, what are you thinking about? You're thinking about two blades versus three blades, three blades versus four. You're thinking about how much ad placement do I place in television, right? Because we hadn't yet realized television is kind of on the way out in terms of reaching lots of people, especially young people. So your whole mental capacity is taken up with those kinds of questions. You're not looking for what's the hot new thing that might introduce a completely different variable into your sales process. So it turns out that Dollar Shave Club didn't just come up with a new business model.
我的意思是，如果你当时是吉列的高管，你在想什么？你在想两片刀片对比三片刀片，三片对比四片。你在想我在电视上投放多少广告位，对吧？因为我们还没有意识到电视在触达大量人群，尤其是年轻人方面已经有点过时了。所以你的全部心理容量都被这些问题占据了。你并没有在寻找可能给你的销售流程引入完全不同变量的热门新事物。事实证明，美元剃须俱乐部不仅提出了一个新的商业模式。
They also came up with a more conversational, casual style of marketing. Here's a clip from one ad. Hi, I'm Mike, founder of DollarShaveClub.com. What is DollarShaveClub.com? Well, for a dollar a month, we send high quality razors right to your door. A dollar! Are the blades any good? No, our blades are f***ing great.
他们还提出了一种更具对话性、更随意的营销风格。这是一段广告片段。嗨，我是迈克，DollarShaveClub.com的创始人。什么是DollarShaveClub.com？嗯，每月只需一美元，我们就把高质量的剃须刀直接送到你家门口。一美元！刀片好用吗？不，我们的刀片好用得要命。
What was the audience reaction to this, Rita? Oh, they loved it. This thing went completely viral on YouTube. And as you probably could hear, Mike's a very personable guy. He's very approachable. And when you think about most of corporate America television ads,
观众对此的反应是什么，丽塔？哦，他们喜欢它。这个东西在YouTube上完全火了。正如你可能听到的，迈克是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。他非常平易近人。当你想到大多数美国企业电视广告时，
they've been run through the PR department in legal and compliance. And they're not really speaking directly to you, the customer, whereas Mike was a master of that and did so for a long time. So this was really his first introduction to the main stage of speaking directly to his target audience, which were younger men, right? And Mike also realized that a lot of these young guys were very frustrated at the experience which were younger men, right? And Mike also realized that a lot of these young guys were very frustrated at the experience Gillette was offering, right? You had to go to a store. Razors are expensive and they're small, so they're catnip for shoplifters. And so
它们都是经过公关部门、法律和合规部门审核的。它们并没有真正直接与你，也就是客户对话，而迈克是这方面的大师，并且长期这样做。所以这确实是他第一次在主舞台上直接与他的目标受众对话，也就是年轻男性，对吧？迈克也意识到，许多这些年轻人对吉列提供的体验感到非常沮丧，对吧？你必须去商店。剃须刀很贵而且很小，所以它们是商店扒手的最爱。所以
what do the stores do? They lock them up in razor fortresses. So you're standing around on a Saturday morning waiting for the friendly, helpful retail employee who's got the keys to come help you unleash this thing. I mean, it's just a really horrible experience as opposed to the convenience of having them to show up on your doorstep. I want to play you an ad that Gillette published around this time. This one featured the tennis champion Roger Federer shaving his face in the mirror. You get in the zone long before the match. Get your head right and focus. On match day, you don't leave anything to chance.
商店会怎么做？他们把它们锁在剃须刀堡垒里。所以你在周六早上站在那里，等待着有钥匙的友好、乐于助人的零售员工来帮你解锁这个东西。我的意思是，这真是一种非常糟糕的体验，而不是让它们出现在你家门口的便利。我想给你播放一个吉列当时发布的广告。这个广告以网球冠军罗杰·费德勒在镜子前刮胡子为特色。在比赛前很久你就会进入状态。调整好心态并专注。在比赛日，你不会留下任何机会。
I get the sense from that ad that Gillette took itself more seriously than Dollar Shave Club, Rita. Oh, absolutely, and so did many other incumbent firms at the time. As I said, you got legal, you got compliance, everybody's saying if the ad is okay, people are worried about brand image. The fact that Mike's video was literally filmed in his warehouse with him wandering around like and it throws in lots of humorous elements like a big stuffed teddy bear and he says,
从那个广告中我感觉到吉列比美元剃须俱乐部更严肃，丽塔。哦，当然，当时许多其他在位公司也是如此。正如我所说，你有法律部门，你有合规部门，每个人都在说如果广告没问题，人们担心品牌形象。迈克视频中实际上是在他的仓库里拍摄的，他四处走动，而且他加入了很多幽默元素，比如一个巨大的毛绒泰迪熊，他说，
hey, you don't need to pay Roger Federer's salary if you buy from us. I mean, he was really poking Gillette in the nose on that. And yes, I think a lot of the big consumer product brands at the time, you know, with celebrity endorsements, a big deal. I don't know how much they paid Federer, but I'm sure it was a lot. So in 2019, Dollar Shave Club put out another ad. This one featured a handful of middle-aged men who didn't look at all like Roger Federer. The men were dancing in towels
嘿，如果你从我们这里购买，你就不需要支付罗杰·费德勒的薪水。我的意思是，他确实是在那方面戳吉列的鼻子。是的，我认为当时很多大型消费品品牌，你知道，名人代言是一件大事。我不知道他们付给费德勒多少钱，但我肯定很多。所以到了2019年，美元剃须俱乐部发布了另一个广告。这个广告以几个看起来一点也不像罗杰·费德勒的中年人为特色。这些男人穿着浴巾跳舞
while they shaved their faces. The video campaign was titled, Dad Bard, and the slogan was, whatever your bard, welcome to the club. That same year, Gillette released its own ad campaign. It was inspired by the Me Too movement and included imagery of men treating women in inappropriate ways
同时刮胡子。这个视频活动名为“老爸身材”，口号是“无论你是什么身材，欢迎加入俱乐部”。同年，吉列发布了自己的广告活动。它的灵感来自“我也是”运动，并包含了男人以不当方式对待女人的意象。
We believe in the best in men. Men need to hold other men accountable. Smile sweetie. Come on. Because the boys watching today Will be the men of tomorrow What was the response to this ad, Rita? Oh, the response was really negative. People felt it was finger-pointing. People felt it was kind of accusatory. Instead of their historical positioning, which was the best a man can get, this is like the
我们相信男人最好的一面。男人需要让其他男人承担责任。笑一个，甜心。来吧。因为今天观看的孩子们将成为明天的男人。对这个广告的反应是什么，丽塔？哦，反应非常负面。人们觉得这是在指责。人们觉得这有点控诉意味。而不是他们历史上的定位，即“男人能达到的最好境界”，这就像是
worst a man can be, right? So I understand that Gillette eventually pivoted to try and get into the subscription business as well and sell Razor as a service. They started a Gillette club. How did that go? Better. Better. They picked up many of the segments that found shopping in the stores to be irritating. There are some men who felt the quality of the shave was better using the traditional Gillette blades. And so they were able to kind of mount a rear guard there, but that's a defensive action. That's not really winning and taking the offensive. It really just stops the bleeding.
男人能达到的最坏境界，对吧？所以我了解到吉列最终也转向尝试进入订阅业务，并销售“剃须刀即服务”。他们启动了“吉列俱乐部”。进展如何？更好。更好。他们吸收了许多觉得在商店购物很烦人的细分市场。有些男人觉得使用传统的吉列刀片刮胡子的质量更好。所以他们能够在那方面建立某种后卫防线，但这是一种防御性行动。那并不是真正的获胜并采取进攻。它实际上只是止血。
So we talked about how Gillette missed two potential inflection points, the subscription model but also this changing tide in the kind of marketing that customers were responding to. What was the long-term effect on Gillette's market dominance, Rita? When Procter & Gamble bought Gillette in 2005, they spent 57 billion dollars for it. Dollar Shaped Club got its going with like Dubin's life savings of 35 grand. I mean, in the past it would be inconceivable that a tiny little upstart literally running out of his apartment, sticking on labels on packages by hand, could be even a modest threat to Mighty Gillette. So if you think about sort of
所以我们谈到了吉列是如何错失了两个潜在的转折点，订阅模式，还有客户所响应的营销方式的这种变化趋势。这对吉列的市场主导地位的长期影响是什么，丽塔？当宝洁公司在2005年收购吉列时，他们花了570亿美元。美元剃须俱乐部是用杜宾大约3.5万美元的积蓄起家的。我的意思是，在过去，一个从公寓里跑出来、手工贴标签的小初创公司，竟然能对强大的吉列构成哪怕是微小的威胁，这简直是不可想象的。所以如果你考虑某种
intellectual deniability, why would you believe that could be true? But what had happened in the interval was some big changes in tech. So Dollar Shave Club could start up without servers, and they didn't have to hire programmers to build custom websites, and they didn't have to manufacture. Manufacturing razors is really hard, and they already had a supply because of Mark's efforts. So I think it was very difficult for the Gillette executives to realize this was real. But it's also the case that you know the market dominance they had for much of the century, much of the 20th century, that has sort of
知识上的不可否认性，你为什么会相信那是真的呢？但在那段时间里发生了一些技术上的重大变化。所以美元剃须俱乐部可以在没有服务器的情况下启动，他们不必雇佣程序员来构建定制网站，也不必进行制造。制造剃须刀真的很难，而且因为马克的努力，他们已经有了供应。所以我认为吉列的高管们很难意识到这是真的。但事实也是，你知道他们在一个世纪，大部分20世纪所拥有的市场主导地位，那种地位已经某种程度上
disappeared. I mean they no longer are in quite as dominant a position as they were through much of the 20th century. And you know don't get me wrong, 50% share in a high margin business like that is nothing to sneeze at. That's a really good business. It's just not as good as it was, right? And I have a lot of credit for the people at Procter & Gamble and Gillette. They really know their game, but the game changed.
消失了。我的意思是，他们不再像20世纪大部分时间那样处于如此主导的地位。而且你知道，别误会我，在这样一个高利润业务中占据50%的份额是不容小觑的。那是一个非常好的生意。只是不像以前那么好了，对吧？我对宝洁和吉列的人有很多敬意。他们真的很懂他们的游戏，但游戏规则变了。
You use the term inflection point to describe situations like what happened with Gillette and Dollar Shave Club. What is an inflection point Rita? Well I define an inflection point as something that changes what is true about the rules around your business typically by a factor of 10 or more. So 10 times faster, 10 times cheaper in the case of Dollar Shave Club, 10 times more convenient or even more than that. And it can take incumbents by surprise, as we saw with Gillette. People forget that, right? So these things seep into this whole world of reality.
你使用“转折点”这个词来描述像吉列和美元剃须俱乐部发生的那种情况。什么是转折点，丽塔？嗯，我将转折点定义为改变了你业务周围规则真实性的事物，通常是10倍或更多。所以快10倍，便宜10倍，在美元剃须俱乐部的案例中，方便10倍甚至更多。而且它会让在位者感到惊讶，正如我们在吉列身上看到的那样。人们忘记了这一点，对吧？所以这些事情渗透到了整个现实世界中。
And then something comes along like internet, digital advertising, e-commerce, changes all those rules, and your system is still operating on the old ones. When we come back, why businesses and people fail to see inflection points and what we can learn from their mistakes. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. The personal care and safety razor company Gillette had been the leader in its industry for nearly a century. When competitors came along, Gillette said, don't fix what isn't broken. The strategy worked until it didn't.
然后像互联网、数字广告、电子商务这样的东西出现了，改变了所有这些规则，而你的系统仍然在旧规则下运行。当我们回来时，为什么企业和个人未能看到转折点，以及我们可以从他们的错误中学到什么。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。个人护理和安全剃须刀公司吉列在近一个世纪里一直是其行业的领导者。当竞争对手出现时，吉列说，不要修理没坏的东西。这个策略奏效了，直到它不再奏效。
When does it make sense to stay the course? And when does it make sense to roll with changing tides? At Columbia Business School, Rita McGrath studies this question. She studies the science of inflection points, a change that dramatically shifts the course of events. Rita, I want to talk about some of the reasons why organizations miss inflection points. In 1995, a man named Cliff Stoll published an article in Newsweek. It was titled, Why the Web Won't Be Nirvana. What did the article say?
什么时候坚持航向是有意义的？什么时候顺应变化的潮流是有意义的？在哥伦比亚商学院，丽塔·麦格拉思研究这个问题。她研究转折点的科学，即一种剧烈改变事件进程的变化。丽塔，我想谈谈组织错失转折点的一些原因。1995年，一个叫克里夫·斯托尔的人在《新闻周刊》上发表了一篇文章。标题是《为什么网络不会成为涅槃》。文章说了什么？
Well, okay, back in 1995, the internet was very new. Computers at the time operated on things called the floppy disks. And things were very primitive. Most of us got our access to the internet, if we were on at all, which most people weren't. By dial-up, you remember? Eh, ah, ah, you know, the modem dial-up. And the visionaries among us were saying, oh, you know, the web is gonna completely replace
嗯，好吧，回到1995年，互联网非常新。当时的计算机运行在一种叫软盘的东西上。事情非常原始。我们大多数人如果上网的话，大多数人并没有上网，是通过拨号上网获得的访问权限，你还记得吗？呃，啊，啊，你知道，调制解调器拨号。而我们中间的远见者说，哦，你知道，网络将完全取代
newspapers and novels and magazines. And Stoll was looking at the reality of 1995 and he was saying, let me get this straight. You're gonna drag a computer to the beach to read your racy romance novel? I don't think so. Yeah, so at one point in this article he says, the truth is no online database will replace your daily newspaper, no CD-ROM can take the place of a competent teacher, and no computer network will change the way government works. And of course, looking back now, that prediction, you know, can seem hilarious, but from what you're
报纸、小说和杂志。而斯托尔看着1995年的现实，他说，让我搞清楚。你要把一台电脑拖到海滩上去读你那本色情的浪漫小说？我不这么认为。是的，所以在文章的某个地方他说，事实是没有任何在线数据库会取代你的日报，没有任何CD-ROM可以取代一位称职的老师，没有任何计算机网络会改变政府运作的方式。当然，现在回过头来看，那个预测，你知道，看起来可能很滑稽，但从你所说的来看，
saying, there's a certain truth to it. At the time, it really didn't seem plausible that these things would dramatically upend our lives, but one of the things that I think Cliff Stoll missed was how much technology was going to change in the coming years. It wasn't an instantaneous change, but it unfolded over five, ten, fifteen, twenty years. Well, and the idea behind a lot of this is it's a bit like the line from the old Hemingway novel, you know, the sun also rises or one character asks another, well, how did you go bankrupt?
它有一定的道理。当时，这些事情会剧烈颠覆我们的生活确实看起来不太可能，但我认为克里夫·斯托尔错失的一点是技术在未来几年将发生多大的变化。这不是瞬间的变化，而是经过了五年、十年、十五年、二十年才展开。嗯，这背后的想法有点像海明威旧小说中的那句台词，你知道，《太阳照常升起》，或者一个角色问另一个，嗯，你是怎么破产的？
And the answer was, well, two ways, gradually and then suddenly. And in the gradual part of that curve, everything looks the same. Nothing looks as though it's changing. And it's very hard for human beings to think about these exponential changes that can come out and really shift what's possible in the world.
答案是，嗯，有两种方式，逐渐地，然后突然地。而在那条曲线的逐渐部分，一切看起来都一样。看起来没有任何变化。人类很难思考这些可能出现并真正改变世界上可能性的指数级变化。
I mean the interesting thing of course is that when we look back, I mean it feels like the whole online revolution was the work of an instant, right? It feels like looking back now in hindsight, it feels like it all happened very quickly, but it actually took a long time. It took about two decades really for widespread broadband service to be widely available for us to carry around these little But it actually took a long time. It took about two decades really for widespread broadband service to be widely available for us to carry around these little computers in our hands and in our pockets where we could access the internet, where we could press a button and it had our credit card information stored. All of these things took time, but looking back it can seem like they were
我的意思是，有趣的是，当然，当我们回顾过去时，我的意思是，感觉整个在线革命是一瞬间的工作，对吧？感觉现在回顾过去，感觉这一切发生得非常快，但实际上花了很长时间。实际上花了大约二十年，宽带服务才广泛普及，让我们随身携带这些小……但实际上花了很长时间。实际上花了大约二十年，宽带服务才广泛普及，让我们随身携带这些小电脑在我们的手中和口袋里，在那里我们可以访问互联网，在那里我们可以按下一个按钮，它就存储了我们的信用卡信息。所有这些事情都需要时间，但回顾过去，它们看起来就像是
the work of an instant. Yeah they do, they do. And I think what's interesting is you kind of go from this will never happen to, hey, what's happening to, well, of course that happened. Yeah. You know, human beings. We're kind of like that when we think about change. I also think that there is a human tendency, if something's going to be very destabilizing to your business or your life, there's kind of a human very destabilizing to your business or your life, there's kind of a human tendency not to want to see it. We talked earlier about how Gillette, the razor company, failed to see the inflection
一瞬间的工作。是的，它们确实是。而且我认为有趣的是，你从“这永远不会发生”变成了“嘿，发生了什么”，再到“嗯，当然发生了”。是的。你知道，人类。当我们思考变化时，我们就是这样。我还认为有一种人类倾向，如果某件事对你的业务或生活非常具有破坏性，有一种人类……非常具有破坏性，有一种人类倾向不想看到它。我们之前谈到了吉列，那家剃须刀公司，未能看到美元剃须俱乐部提供的订阅模式的转折点。你谈到的另一家公司是柯达。我们大多数人都熟悉这个品牌，但不太熟悉一个叫安东尼奥·佩雷斯的人的故事，他在2003年加入了公司。他之前在惠普？是的。所以，安东尼奥·佩雷斯将惠普的打印机业务从无到有发展成了，我想，一个70亿美元左右的业务。
point of a subscription model that Dollar Shave Club offered. There's another company that you talk about, Kodak. Most of us are familiar with the brand, but not as familiar with the story of a man named Antonio Perez, who joined the company in 2003. He had previously been at Hewlett-Packard? Yeah. So, Antonio Perez grew Hewlett-Packard's printer business from kind of nothing to, I think, a seven billion something business.
他在竞选惠普首席执行官时失败了，卡莉·菲奥莉娜被任命了。现在她有一个问题，他也有一个问题。她必须弄清楚怎么处理他，因为他显然是该公司合格的继任者，那里有两个交战的阵营。所以她让他围绕打印开辟了自己的空间，所以他们与柯达建立了合资企业，持续了几年。佩雷斯想收购柯达。我不认为他让董事会同意了这一点。
And he lost out in his bid to become CEO at HP, and Carly Fiorino was named instead. Now she's got a problem and he's got a problem. She's got to figure out what to do with him because he was very clearly a qualified heir apparent at that company, and there were kind of two warring camps there. So she kind of let him carve out his own space around printing, so they forged a joint venture with Kodak, which went on for a few years. Perez wanted to buy Kodak. I don't think he got the board to buy into that.
最终当首席执行官离职并空出柯达的位置时，他担任了那个角色。他在那个角色中所做的是，他做出了后来被证明是相当致命的决定，即在屏幕变得如此好以至于我们不需要打印它们的时候，将整个公司瞄准打印。我不知道这一点，但我的信念和其他观察这种情况的人会同意，这有点受自我驱动。
And eventually when the CEO rolled up and opened up a Kodak, he took that role. And what he did in that role was he made the, what turned out to be pretty fatal decision to aim the whole company at printing just at that period when screens were getting so good that we didn't need to print them. And I don't know this, but my belief and others observing the situation would agree that it was kind of ego-fueled.
他要向惠普董事会和其他所有人展示他们没有给他那个角色是多么错误，并利用柯达作为他实现这一目标的工具。所以关于安东尼奥·佩雷斯的故事，丽塔，令人震惊的是，他在惠普时在打印机上押注取得了巨大的成功，事实上，正如你刚才指出的，它产生了数十亿美元的收入，同样的策略，五年后，十年后在另一家公司，结果完全不同。确实。我们经常看到这种情况，你知道，特定的策略在特定的时间和地点是成功的。
He was going to show the HP board and all the others how wrong they were to not have given him that role and was using Kodak as his vehicle to do that. So what's striking about the Antonio Perez story Rita is that he had been wildly successful betting on printers while he was at HP and in fact as you just pointed out it had produced billions of dollars in revenue the very same play, five years later, ten years later at a different company, completely different outcome. Indeed. And we see that a lot, you know, that there is a time and a place for a particular
当条件改变时，你不能只是简单地重复。组织可能错失转折点的另一个原因是时机。我们可以看到试图迟到地赶上潮流，比如，你知道，像吉列在转折点过去后提供订阅服务。但你说公司也可能过早地赶上转折点。我理解视频租赁公司百视达就是这种情况？是的。所以百视达是另一个迷人的故事，因为我认为我们理解错了。百视达总是被描述为，哦，愚蠢的老公司，从未看到流媒体的力量。这其实不是真的。有一位非常著名的零售转型专家叫约翰·安提奥科，他被任命为那里的首席执行官。
strategy to be successful. And when the conditions change, you can't just rinse repeat. Another reason organizations can miss out on inflection points is timing. We can see how trying to jump on a bandwagon late, like, you know, like Gillette offering a subscription service after the inflection point had passed. But you say that companies can also jump on an inflection point too early. I understand this was the case with the video rental company Blockbuster? Yes. So Blockbuster is another one of those fascinating stories because I think we get it wrong. Blockbuster always gets told as, oh, dumb old company, never saw the power of streaming. And that's not actually true. There was a very well-known retail turnaround guy called John Antiochus who was put in the CEO role there.
公司陷入了困境。竞争非常激烈。他们的利润率被压缩了。他们有两件事让客户绝对疯狂。一个是滞纳金。另一个是如果你有一部非常受欢迎的电影，百视达当时在店里只会买四五部。
The company was in trouble. There was a lot of competition. Their margins were getting squeezed. They had two things that drove customers absolutely crazy. One was the late fees. The other was that if you had a movie that came out that was really super popular, Blockbuster would only buy four or five to keep in the store at the time.
所以热门的新电影你经常不得不等待，那些是令人恼火的事情。所以安提奥科看了看这个，他说，嗯，我认为我们需要做的是，我认为我们需要取消滞纳金。我认为流媒体是一回事。他实际上与安然公司，是的，就是那个安然，合作建立了数字基础设施，使这成为可能。但同样，我们谈论的是在高速宽带普及之前。这甚至比Netflix广泛采用流媒体早了好几年。所以从技术上讲，那有点早。但发生的事情是
So the hot new movies you often had to wait for and those were things that were irritating. So Antioch took a look at this and he said, well, what I think we need to do, I think we need to get rid of late fees. I think streaming is a thing. And he actually partnered with Enron, yes, that Enron, to build out a digital infrastructure that would make it possible to do that. But again, we're talking kind of before high speed broadband. This was several years before even Netflix adopted streaming in a widespread way. So that was a little early technologically. But what happened in
在这一点的后半部分，安提奥科的举措每个大约需要花费2亿。所以流媒体部分和结束滞纳金，这是他们利润率的重要组成部分。而当时的母公司是一家叫维亚康姆的公司，它根本没有那种胃口。所以维亚康姆最终让百视达进行了首次公开募股，百视达进入市场时有点虚弱。转型尚未发生。
the back half of this was Antiochus moves were going to cost about 200 million apiece. So the streaming part and the ending late fees, which was a big part of their profit margin. And the parent company at the time was a company called Viacom, which just didn't have the appetite for that. So Viacom ended up floating an initial public offering with Blockbuster, who went to market kind of weakened. The turnaround had not yet taken place.
所以很多投资者非常怀疑。伊坎，一位非常著名的激进投资者，看到了机会，猛扑过来，买下了公司，看了安提奥科做事的计划，并没有比前任所有者有更好的感觉。所以他取消了这两件事。事实是，如果你考虑代表某种我称之为“时间零点”事件的东西。所以事情就在这里，你可以给它拍照，它在《华尔街日报》的头版，我们都知道它在这里。等到那时，肯定太晚了，因为现在你处于被动模式，如果有什么超额利润可赚，
And so a lot of investors were very skeptical. Icon, who's a very famous activist investor, sees the opportunity, swoops in, buys the company, looks at Antiochus plans to do things and doesn't have any better feeling about it than the previous owner did. And so he cancels both of those things. The reality is, if you think about something that represents, I'll call it a time zero event. So the thing is here, you can take pictures of it, it's in the front page of the Wall Street Journal, we all know it's here. By the time you wait till then, it's definitely too late, because now you're in reactive mode, and if there were any excess profits to be made,
先行者已经得到了。但你也不想动得太早。这就是我认为很多这些吸引了大量风险投资资金的热门技术陷入困境的地方，因为有很多生态系统考虑需要纳入考量。有很多，我能得到我需要的人才吗？我能得到我需要的房地产吗？我能弄清楚这怎么运作吗？所以如果你考虑自动驾驶技术，自动驾驶汽车技术，我不知道你怎么样，但我们本应在2016年拥有自动驾驶技术。还记得吗？
the early movers would have gotten them. But you also don't want to move too early. And that's where I think a lot of these big, buzzy technologies that manage to attract a lot of venture capital money get themselves in trouble because there's a lot of ecosystem considerations that need to be taken into account. There's a lot of, can I get the talent that I need? Can I get the real estate that I need? Can I figure out how this is gonna work? So if you think about autonomous technology, autonomous vehicle technology, I don't know about you, but we were gonna have autonomous technology in 2016. Remember that?
而且它仍然是一种有待实现的承诺，因为我认为技术足够难，但当你谈论某种将影响数亿人日常生活的事情时，有你必须解决的风险，有所有权制度，什么道路对这些东西来说是安全的。所以除了仅仅搞定技术之外，还有一个完整的社会维度需要发生，而这已经足够难了。
And it's still kind of a promise to be gotten because I think the technology is hard enough, but when you're talking about something that's going to affect the everyday lives of potentially hundreds of millions of people, there is risk you have to sort out, there's ownership regimes, what roads are safe for these things to go on. And so there's a whole social dimension that needs to happen, in addition to just getting the tech right, and that's hard enough.
你描述了转折点的生命周期，你说它们通常有四个阶段。你能带我了解这四个阶段吗，丽塔？所以一开始，人们看到了潜力，对吧？所以自动驾驶汽车，对吧？他们就像，哦天哪，你知道，这难道不棒吗？老年人不必失去独立性，而且，你知道，我们将能够在城市里拥有这些受监管的东西，它将减少污染，这将是惊人的。所以有一个炒作周期。然后发生的是炒作没有达到其预期，至少在短期内。所以第一年或两年，然后我们有，
You've described the life cycle of inflection points, and you say there are often four stages to them. Can you walk me through these four stages, Rita? So in the beginning, people see the potential, right? So autonomous cars, right? They're like, oh my God, you know, wouldn't this be awesome? Older people won't have to lose their independence, and, you know, we'll be able to have these regulated things in cities and it'll reduce pollution and it's going to be amazing. So there's a hype cycle. Then what happens is the hype doesn't deliver to its expectations, at least in the short run. So the first year or two, and then we have,
你知道，人工智能寒冬来临，每个人都感到幻灭，哦，你知道，我们以为它会做从可口可乐推出到登月的所有事情，然后每个人都感到幻灭，但发生的是那个时期的幸存者实际上已经做出了一些很酷的东西。所以如果你想想美元剃须俱乐部，如果你想想之前发生的事情，早期的互联网，记得90年代末和互联网泡沫破裂，每个人都说哦，这个互联网东西永远不会成为一回事，你。我们都应该忘记它，忘记它。但从中诞生了亚马逊、eBay，一些早期真正成功的互联网商业
you know, the AI winter sets in and everybody's disillusioned and, oh, you know, we thought it was going to do everything from making Cocoa still launching to the moon and then everybody gets disillusioned but what happens is the survivors of that period have actually worked some cool stuff at now. So if you think about Dollar Shave Club, if you think about what came before, the early internet, remember the late 90s and the dot com crash and everybody said oh this internet thing is never going to be a thing, you. We should all just forget it, forget it. But out of that came Amazon, eBay, some of the early really successful internet commerce
项目，这向我们展示了这在我们的生活中可能是有用的。所以下一个周期是这种幻灭的低谷，但要等待那些行不通的东西，直到你找到行得通的东西。然后在第三阶段，你有人们说，哇，哦，现在我明白了。我可以用那个东西做X、Y、Z。所以你看到的是机会的绽放和新应用的绽放。那是真正令人兴奋的时期，对吧？那是你现在实际上看到真正的成长型企业围绕着
programs which showed us that this could be useful in our lives. And so the next cycle is this trough of disillusionment, but the waiting out of the stuff that isn't going to work until you find the stuff that works. And then in the third stage, you have people saying, whoa, oh, now I get it. I could use that thing to do X, Y, Z. So what you see is this flowering of opportunities and this flowering of new applications. And that's the really exciting period, right? That's the period where you're now actually seeing real growth businesses build around
那些东西建立的时期。我会说美元剃须俱乐部将是一个很好的例子。然后你有那种，哦是的，这很正常。这就像每个人，你是什么意思，在高速宽带之前有一个时代？对。鉴于你可能对转折点太早，但也可能太晚，时机显然很重要。你说有一些警告信号表明转折点正在与你擦肩而过。这些信号有哪些，丽塔？
that stuff. And I'd say Dollar Shave Club would be a great example of that. And then you have the kind of, oh yeah, this is just normal. This is like everyone, what do you mean there was a time before high speed broadband? Right. Given that you can be too early to an inflection point, but also too late to it, timing clearly matters. You say there are warning signs that an inflection point is passing you by. What are some of these signs, Rita?
嗯，我喜欢看它的方式是，如果你想象这个，正如我所说，一个时间零点，然后你反向工作，你只是说在这种情况真正发生之前必须是真的什么？我喜欢对公司做的是，我们会做一个图表。我称之为“早期预警信号模型”。然后我们观察它。然后我们说，等一下，如果这发生了，那发生了，这其他事情发生了，哇，还有其他事情正在发生，也许现在是我们需要真正评估这一点以立即采取行动的时候了。所以让我举个例子。在2020年、21年，我正在与一家制药公司合作
Well, the way I like to look at it is if you imagine this, as I said, a time zero with it, and then you work backward, you just say what would have to be true before this could actually happen? And what I like to do with companies is we'll make actually like a chart. I call it an early warnings signal model. And then we watch it. And then we say, wait a minute, if this happens and that happens and this other thing happens and whoa, there's this other thing happening, maybe now's the time we need to really evaluate this for taking action now. So let me give an example. In 2020, 21, I was working with a pharmaceutical company
他们面临的一个大问题是，嗯，技术，在线或某种技术参与会成为获得医疗保健的第一患者接触点吗？所以如果办公室里没有医生，如果你是销售代表，那有点问题。所以我们看了看，我们说，为了让这种情况真正发生，必须是真的什么？
and one of the big questions they had was, well, is the tech, is online or some kind of tech involvement going to be the first patient port of call for access to healthcare? So if there's no doctors in offices, that's kind of a problem if you're a sales rep. So we looked at that and we said, well, what would have to be true for this to actually happen?
并且有一堆事情必须是真的。医疗保险和医疗补助必须为不在设施中完成的服务，为在家中完成或通过技术中介完成的服务找出支付模式。你可能必须有立法行动，说，嘿，你知道，电子交付的药物或以任何方式交付的药物一样合法。所以我们大概在两年半后回去，我们看了看我们当时开发的那些早期预警，你看到的是是的，是的，是的，是的。事实上，我们预料到的一堆事情现在开始发生了。当谈到说，嘿，我们需要
And there's a bunch of things that would have to be true. Medicare and Medicaid would have to figure out payment models for services that were not done in a facility, for services that were done either at home or mediated technologically. You probably would have to have legislative action which says, hey, you know, drugs delivered electronically or as legitimate as drugs delivered any what way. So we went back probably two and a half years later and we looked at those early warnings that we had developed back in the day and what you saw was yes, yes, yes, and yes. In fact, a bunch of the things that we'd anticipated were now starting to happen. When it came time to saying, hey, do we
雇佣一名数据科学家吗？答案是肯定的。当谈到说，让我们弄清楚在无医生环境中营销是什么样子。还有很多其他事情。例如，许多私人医生诊所被卖给了大型参与者。你看到了支付方、保险公司的巨大影响，等等等等，所以这导致他们采取了真正的战略转变。你知道，我在报纸行业工作了很多年，丽塔，在转到广播和音频之前。
need to hire a data scientist? The answer was yes. When it came time to say, let's figure out what marketing looks like in a doctor-free environment. And there were a whole bunch of other things as well. For example, a lot of private physician practices were being sold to large players. You saw the disproportionate influence of the paying, the insurance companies, and, and, and, and, and, and so it caused them to take a real strategic shift. You know, I worked in the newspaper business for many years, Rita, before moving to radio and to audio.
但我记得在我报纸生涯的某个时刻，我实际上不是在纸上读报纸，而是在网上读。当时，我认为我合作的公司仍然有点，你知道，他们对数字新闻以及人们真的会在网上广泛阅读东西的想法持矛盾态度。但你指出的其中一件事
But I remember there was a point in my newspaper career where I was actually not reading the newspaper on the page, but I was reading it online. And at the time, I think the companies that I worked with were still sort of, you know, they were ambivalent about digital journalism and the idea that people would really read things in a widespread way online. But one of the things that you point out
但我记得在我报社职业生涯的某个阶段，我实际上已经不再阅读纸质报纸，而是开始在线阅读了。当时，我想我所供职的公司对数字新闻以及人们是否真的会广泛地在线阅读内容还持有一种矛盾的态度。但你指出的其中一点是
is that when you yourself or the employees at your company are not using your product. It's a warning sign It's basically a canary in the coal mine It is and a very good one, you know that that it doesn't cost you anything to see what people are actually doing So I'll never forget. I was some years back probably in the late Right around 2000. I was doing some work with Nokia in a program called Choices, which was for the people that were in their new product development company. And at the time,
就是当你自己或你公司的员工不再使用你们的产品时。这是一个警告信号，基本上就是煤矿里的金丝雀。确实如此，而且是一个非常好的信号，你知道，看看人们实际上在做什么并不需要付出任何代价。所以我永远不会忘记。那是几年前，大概是在2000年左右。我当时在诺基亚参与一个名为“选择”的项目，那是为他们新产品开发公司的员工准备的。当时，
I was working for a lot of telecom companies. It was a very hot area. And so as I traveled around the world, I would always go to phone stores. So in the airport or on the street, and you'd watch like what was going on in the physical phone store, because it would tell you a lot about market share and who was hot and who was not, and what were the salespeople pushing and all that kind of thing. And what I started to see was the section of the store devoted to Nokia products was getting smaller and smaller and smaller. And so I was with this class and I said to people, well, tell me what you learn when you go visit a phone store.
我为许多电信公司工作。那是一个非常热门的领域。所以当我环游世界时，我总是会去手机店。在机场或街上，你会观察实体手机店里发生了什么，因为这能告诉你很多关于市场份额、谁是热门、谁不是，以及销售人员在推销什么之类的事情。我开始看到，商店里专门用于诺基亚产品的区域变得越来越小。所以我当时和这个班级在一起，我对大家说，好吧，告诉我当你们去参观手机店时学到了什么。
And the room went completely silent. And I said, well, nobody has any ideas. And they looked at me and they said, we don't visit phone stores. I said, excuse me. They said, no, you know, R&D sends us the new phones with the new features to test out and we give them our feedback and we don't ever go to a phone store. And it was like, what? And you know, that's well intentioned, but it's an example of the blind spots you can create when you create these special channels for your people that don't kind of put them in the position of the customer. Yeah and of course if you're actually you know you're working at a company
房间里一片寂静。我说，好吧，没人有想法吗？他们看着我说，我们不去手机店。我说，抱歉，你说什么？他们说，不，你知道，研发部门会把带有新功能的新手机寄给我们测试，我们给出反馈，我们从不去手机店。当时我就想，什么？你知道，这出发点是好的，但这正是一个例子，说明当你为员工创建这些特殊渠道，而不让他们站在客户的角度时，会产生怎样的盲点。是的，当然，如果你实际上是在一家公司工作，
that makes some kind of product and you have your employees at that company who are buying products from a rival, in some ways it tells you that the people who are presumably your most loyal, who should be your most loyal customers are in fact not your loyal customers and that should raise red flags about customers in general. Well, what it tells you is there's, I'll use the language of Clay Christensen and Tony Ulwick here, there's a job to be done
生产某种产品，而你公司的员工却在购买竞争对手的产品，在某种程度上，这告诉你，那些本应是你最忠诚的客户，实际上并不是你的忠诚客户，这应该为客户的整体情况敲响警钟。嗯，它告诉你的是，我会在这里使用克莱·克里斯滕森和托尼·乌尔威克的语言，有一个“待办任务”
that whatever you're offering isn't doing. And the job to be done theory basically says, don't think about customers buying your product or service, think about them hiring your product or service to get a job done in their lives. And if there's a missing job, it's not that your employees don't admire and appreciate whatever you do,
是你所提供的产品无法完成的。待办任务理论基本上是说，不要考虑客户购买你的产品或服务，要考虑他们“雇佣”你的产品或服务来完成他们生活中的某项任务。如果有一个缺失的任务，并不是说你的员工不钦佩和欣赏你所做的一切，
but whatever you're doing isn't covering something they need to get done. And so they're gonna use an alternative. And that's valuable information. Sometimes, sticking with what you've always done makes perfect sense. But what worked yesterday isn't always guaranteed to work tomorrow. When we come back, how to successfully spot inflection points. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
而是你所做的一切并没有涵盖他们需要完成的事情。所以他们会使用替代品。这是有价值的信息。有时，坚持你一直所做的事情是有道理的。但昨天有效的方法并不总是能保证明天也有效。当我们回来时，将探讨如何成功发现转折点。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. There are times in all our lives when doing the same old thing no longer works. The strategies that once helped you excel have now led to a plateau. The things that helped you stand out at work have become yesterday's news. Rita McGrath is the author of Seeing Around Corners, How to Spot Inflection Points in Business Before They Happen. She says there is a science to spotting inflection points. Rita, in the late 1990s, a man named Ivan Seidenberg was leading Bell Atlantic Telephone Company.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们所有人的生活中，总有一些时候，做同样的老一套事情不再奏效了。曾经帮助你出类拔萃的策略现在导致了停滞。那些曾经帮助你在工作中脱颖而出的事情已经成了昨日黄花。丽塔·麦格拉思是《转角遇见未来：如何在商业转折点发生前发现它们》一书的作者。她说，发现转折点是有科学依据的。丽塔，在20世纪90年代末，一个叫伊万·赛登伯格的人领导着贝尔大西洋电话公司。
At this time, landlines were the norm and there was no indication that they were going anywhere. It was a hugely profitable company. But Ivan Seidenberg had a vision. What did he see? Well, I think to really understand Seidenberg's story, you actually have to start a little bit earlier with the breakup of AT&T. And this was Ma Bell. I mean, talk about the ultimate monopoly.
当时，固定电话是常态，没有任何迹象表明它们会消失。那是一家利润极其丰厚的公司。但伊万·赛登伯格有一个愿景。他看到了什么？嗯，我认为要真正理解赛登伯格的故事，你实际上必须从更早一点的AT&T拆分开始。那就是“贝尔妈妈”。我的意思是，谈谈终极垄断。
There was a show in the 70s called Rowan and Martin's Laugh-In where there was a character that pretended to be an operator for the phone company. Mr. Buckley, there's no reason on earth for you to feel personally persecuted. We may be the only phone company in town, but we sock it to everybody. Mr. Buckley, there's no reason on earth for you to feel personally persecuted. We may be the only phone company in town, but we sock it to everybody. So you have to kind of go all the way back to that. So a lot of telecom inherited this monopoly, guaranteed revenue, very profitable business, which you didn't have to work very hard. I mean, you had to deliver on your service. The regulators would ding you if you didn't provide reliable, which you didn't have to work very hard. I mean, you had to deliver on your service.
70年代有一个节目叫《罗恩和马丁的笑话秀》，里面有一个角色假装是电话公司的接线员。巴克利先生，你没有任何理由感到被个人迫害。我们可能是城里唯一的电话公司，但我们对每个人都毫不留情。巴克利先生，你没有任何理由感到被个人迫害。我们可能是城里唯一的电话公司，但我们对每个人都毫不留情。所以你必须追溯到那个时候。因此，许多电信公司继承了这种垄断、保证的收入、非常有利可图的业务，你不需要非常努力工作。我的意思是，你必须提供服务。如果你不提供可靠的服务，监管机构会惩罚你，你不需要非常努力工作。我的意思是，你必须提供服务。
The regulators would ding you if you didn't provide reliable service and you didn't offer service to rural areas, but in exchange for doing that, you kind of had the market to yourself. So what Seidenberg did, and he had an interesting story. He was the ultimate insider, wasn't a super educated man, worked his way up through the ranks, and kind of thought about what comes after copper wires and what could happen in the future. And I think probably the major incitement was to say, hey, a lot of these baby bells, as they called them, really had no idea how to compete like a regular commercial company,
监管机构会因为你不提供可靠的服务，或者不向农村地区提供服务而惩罚你，但作为交换，你基本上拥有了市场。所以赛登伯格所做的是，他有一个有趣的故事。他是终极的内部人士，不是一个受过高等教育的人，通过层层晋升，并思考铜线之后会发生什么，以及未来可能发生什么。我认为主要的激励因素可能是说，嘿，很多这些所谓的“小贝尔”公司，真的不知道如何像一家普通的商业公司那样竞争，
and he didn't want to end up like that. And so one of the things he did was he organized a merger of Bell Atlantic with GTE, which at the time was this kind of cool technology provider at the time, and he thought that that company could teach what was called Bell Atlantic about the new technologies, the new things, and he was kind of blown away by that. So they renamed the company Verizon and prompted to get out actually of these pretty profitable legacy businesses and start exploring some of these new technologies. So he did really controversial things like sell
他不想落得那样的下场。所以他做的一件事是组织了贝尔大西洋与GTE的合并，GTE在当时是一家相当酷的技术提供商，他认为那家公司可以教导所谓的贝尔大西洋关于新技术、新事物的知识，他对此感到非常震撼。所以他们把公司更名为Verizon，并促使公司实际上退出了这些利润丰厚的传统业务，开始探索一些新技术。所以他做了一些非常有争议的事情，比如卖掉
off physical phone books. Can you imagine that? Tell me a little bit about what he did when it came to selling off some of Verizon's landline assets because he wasn't so much you know depriving customers of landline access but he was saying as a company that might be less of our future than it is today. You know he found ways of servicing them for less money. He eventually converted a lot of the big pipes, not the copper pipes right to the home, but the big pipes to FIOS. The fiber optic cable.
实体电话簿。你能想象吗？跟我说说他在出售Verizon的一些固定电话资产时做了什么，因为他并不是在剥夺客户使用固定电话的权利，而是在说，作为一家公司，这可能不再是我们未来的重点。你知道，他找到了以更低成本服务他们的方法。他最终将许多大管道，不是通往家庭的铜管，而是大管道转换成了FIOS。光纤电缆。
Yeah, you could still have a copper line in your house, but it would be connected to fiber optic network. Then the fiber optic network would allow you to have broadband. It would allow you to compete with the cable companies, which he saw as a huge opportunity. And it was, if you remember back in the day, and again, I feel like I'm retelling ancient history, but it's not that long ago. Before we had cable TV, we had network TV and cable TV was seen as this huge advance
是的，你的房子里仍然可以有铜线，但它会连接到光纤网络。然后光纤网络将允许你拥有宽带。它将允许你与有线电视公司竞争，他认为这是一个巨大的机会。而且确实如此，如果你还记得过去的日子，再说一次，我觉得我在重述古代历史，但这并没有过去太久。在我们有有线电视之前，我们有网络电视，而有线电视被视为一个巨大的进步，
because in the early, early days of cable, you didn't even, you didn't have ads, right? You could have ad free television on demand, 500 channels, you know, it was, and, and those cable companies, again, they were protected as local monopolies in the early stages. They were considered to be natural monopolies and governments to provide them with the capital to build out these networks basically said okay Comcast you have New Jersey Spectrum you've got New York and you could guarantee that the customers that were interested in that product could buy the service there. So Verizon said hey wait a minute I don't have to be a cable company but I could compete using
因为在有线电视的早期，你甚至没有广告，对吧？你可以按需观看无广告电视，500个频道，你知道，它是……而且那些有线电视公司，同样，它们在早期阶段作为地方垄断受到保护。它们被认为是自然垄断，政府为了提供资金让它们建立这些网络，基本上说，好吧，康卡斯特，你拥有新泽西州；频谱，你拥有纽约；你可以保证对该产品感兴趣的客户可以在那里购买服务。所以Verizon说，嘿，等一下，我不必成为一家有线电视公司，但我可以使用
fiber optic lines so he decided that revenue looked pretty good. You say that Ivan Seidenberg did two things right. One, he was continuously adapting and two, he was able to disengage. What do you mean by this, Rita? So disengagement is the process of recognizing when something is just not going to be carrying your future forward. So you know, mailing DVDs in the mail was, you know, most of Netflix's customers I doubt even have a DVD player anymore. So that was clearly going to be a business which was ending. So I think there's a way of disengaging which is respectful, you know,
光纤线路进行竞争，所以他决定那部分收入看起来相当不错。你说伊万·赛登伯格做了两件正确的事。第一，他不断适应；第二，他能够脱身。丽塔，你这是什么意思？所以脱身是一个过程，即认识到某件事将无法承载你的未来。所以你知道，邮寄DVD，你知道，Netflix的大多数客户我怀疑甚至不再有DVD播放机了。所以这显然将是一项即将结束的业务。所以我认为有一种脱身方式是尊重的，你知道，
which said, hey, you know, the people that built this business have a lot to be commended, but it's not going to be a business for the future and so we have to figure out how to get resources and people and assets out of them, hopefully in a way that's not too painful, so that we can repurpose those things to what the future is going to hold. I'm struck by the fact that very often when we think about innovation we're often not thinking about this aspect of innovation, which is we're always thinking about what we can build that's new.
它说，嘿，你知道，建立这项业务的人有很多值得称赞的地方，但它不会是未来的业务，所以我们必须弄清楚如何将资源、人员和资产从中撤出，希望以一种不太痛苦的方式，这样我们就可以将这些东西重新用于未来。我感到震惊的是，当我们思考创新时，我们往往没有考虑到创新的这一方面，即我们总是思考我们可以建立什么新的东西。
But of course, in order to build something that's new, we might have to give up something that we've been building for a long time. We might have to give up the old, but of course the two things actually work in a symbiotic fashion. They do have to work together. And I don't know about your workplace,
但当然，为了建立新的东西，我们可能不得不放弃我们长期以来一直在建立的东西。我们可能不得不放弃旧的，但当然这两件事实际上是以共生方式运作的。它们确实必须协同工作。我不知道你的工作场所如何，
but I think about my place. I mean, I work for a 250-year-old-plus university. It's had a lot of time to collect cobwebs and stuff that's in the corners and what's in those closets. Nobody's looked for 35 years. And so if you imagine a world where maybe every quarter you just announce a day or two of simplification, we're just going to stop doing stupid stuff that everybody knows doesn't really contribute to value, but that we're doing anyway.
但我想到我的地方。我的意思是，我为一所拥有250多年历史的大学工作。它有很长的时间来收集角落里的蜘蛛网和那些壁橱里的东西。35年来没人看过。所以如果你想象一个世界，也许每个季度你只是宣布一两天“简化日”，我们只是要停止做每个人都知道对价值没有真正贡献，但我们却一直在做的愚蠢事情。
And that's kind of a really mini version of disengagement, but I think it's valuable and it's not expensive and it's something you could do wherever you are in your organization. Besides the challenge of just noticing things that have been around for a long time and that have just simply faded away from our attention, there's also the fact that we get attached to things that we have built. We have emotional connections to the things we've built. These are our babies, these are our children. We're not willing to cast them aside.
这是一种非常迷你的脱身版本，但我认为它很有价值，而且成本不高，这是你在组织中任何地方都可以做的事情。除了注意到那些存在了很长时间并且已经从我们的注意力中消失的事情的挑战之外，还有一个事实是，我们对我们建造的东西产生了依恋。我们对我们建造的东西有情感联系。这些是我们的宝贝，是我们的孩子。我们不愿意抛弃它们。
But of course, if you don't cast some of the things that you do as a company or an organization or as a person aside, if you can't cast them aside, it's very hard to move forward. It is, it is. So can I tell you one of my favorite stories about this? This is a story of the postal service, which is an unlikely place to look for really interesting management innovations, but so be it. So I had a gentleman in my class who worked for the postal service, and the branch that he was manager of had this giant analog machine. It was like sort and stack and people knew how to use it.
但当然，如果你不抛弃作为公司、组织或个人所做的一些事情，如果你不能抛弃它们，就很难前进。确实，确实。所以我能告诉你关于这个的最喜欢的故事之一吗？这是一个关于邮政服务的故事，这是一个不太可能寻找真正有趣的创新管理的地方，但事实就是如此。所以我的班上有一位先生在邮政服务部门工作，他管理的部门有一台巨大的模拟机器。它就像分类和堆叠，人们知道如何使用它。
And it sort of occupied the middle of the facility. And everybody that was in the place worked with this machine. And they decided that they needed to become more digital. And this big machine was going to get replaced by a bunch of smaller units that could do more specific things and it was going to cost less and it would be less vulnerable to breakdowns and everything. So the machine was supposed to be less and it would be less vulnerable to breakdowns and everything. So the machine was supposed to be decommissioned over the course of a weekend. So you can imagine his surprise when Thursday night a group of his people come to him and
它占据了设施的中间位置。在这个地方工作的每个人都使用这台机器。他们决定需要变得更加数字化。这台大机器将被一堆可以做更具体事情的小型单元所取代，成本会更低，而且不容易发生故障等等。所以这台机器本应在周末期间退役。所以你可以想象当周四晚上他的一群员工来找他时，他的惊讶，
he said, boss, yeah, well we want to talk to you about the machine. And he's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, we spent months on this. We've talked, we've all agreed. You've all said it was good. And the people said to him, oh yeah, yeah, we get it. We're totally, we're ready to move on. It's just, you know, that machine has been a big part of our lives for a long period of time. A lot of us started working here when we were 18, you know, and that machine has been there every day. It's
他说，老板，是的，我们想和你谈谈这台机器。他说，哇，哇，哇，我们在这上面花了几个月的时间。我们谈过了，我们都同意了。你们都说这很好。员工们对他说，哦，是的，是的，我们明白了。我们完全准备好继续前进了。只是，你知道，那台机器在很长一段时间里一直是我们生活的重要组成部分。我们很多人18岁时就开始在这里工作，你知道，那台机器每天都在那里。它
just, you know, and it's going to be a big change for us. And they said, well, we want to say goodbye. And he's like, you want to say goodbye to a machine? They said, yeah. So they decided they wanted to have an Irish wake. Wow. The next night, the next night. It was amazing. There were people giving speeches that
只是，你知道，这对我们来说将是一个巨大的改变。他们说，好吧，我们想告别。他说，你们想跟一台机器告别？他们说，是的。所以他们决定举行一场爱尔兰式的守灵仪式。哇。第二天晚上，第二天晚上。太神奇了。有人发表了演讲，
were keeping people like screwing off little pieces of the machine to take home as keepsakes. But I've always thought that was a really lovely story because it represents both sides. You know, it represents the sadness of having to give up something that you've, that's been part of who you are for a long time and the need to do that and move on. Another example of a company that found an innovative way to ride an inflection point was Procter & Gamble.
有人把机器的小零件拧下来带回家作为纪念品。但我一直认为这是一个非常可爱的故事，因为它代表了双方。你知道，它代表了不得不放弃你长期以来作为你一部分的东西的悲伤，以及必须这样做并继续前进的需要。另一家找到创新方式来驾驭转折点的公司是宝洁公司。
They had come up with a water purification chemical, but it was not taking off. Tell me that story, Rita. Yeah, so the thing was called Pure, if I remember properly. And the original concept for it was that there would be this huge market of providing safe drinking water in places which didn't have reliable access to it. But you know, it's really hard, I think, if you've always lived your life in a developed country where you open the tap and safe drinking water comes out, to really understand the day-to-day circumstances of people who don't have that luxury. And what they came to realize was that if they tried to do this thing as a commercial
他们发明了一种水净化化学品，但并没有流行起来。丽塔，告诉我那个故事。是的，如果我没记错的话，那个东西叫Pure。最初的概念是，在那些无法获得可靠饮用水的地方，提供安全饮用水将有一个巨大的市场。但你知道，如果你一直生活在发达国家，打开水龙头就有安全饮用水，要真正理解那些没有这种奢侈的人的日常处境，真的很难。他们最终意识到，如果他们试图将此作为一项商业
enterprise that it was going to be very difficult for the people living in those areas to access it because safe water was just one of their problems, right? They were, you know, there's sanitation concerns, there's other health concerns, and they've got so little resources to take what little they had and spend it on safe water, you know, maybe you'll just take the risk. So it wasn't, they banged away at it for a while, but it just became clear that unless the government took an interest or an NGO took an interest to that, it just wasn't going to be a commercial enterprise.
企业来做，那么生活在这些地区的人们将很难获得它，因为安全用水只是他们的问题之一，对吧？他们有卫生方面的担忧，有其他健康方面的担忧，他们拥有的资源太少了，要把仅有的一点资源花在安全用水上，你知道，也许你只会冒险。所以，他们在那上面努力了一段时间，但很明显，除非政府或非政府组织对此感兴趣，否则它不会成为一项商业企业。
But then I believe it was a series of natural disasters that they were able to basically go in as a charity and say, hey, look, we will donate this, you know, to keep people from getting terrible illnesses and whatnot. And that then did attract the attention of the NGO community, of the governmental community. And it became, I wouldn't say, a wildly profitable business for them, but at least a viable business for them. I understand that it also had significant, you know, public relations benefits, because now they were in the business not public relations benefits, because now they were in the business not just of making money,
但后来我相信是一系列自然灾害，他们能够基本上以慈善机构的身份进入，说，嘿，看，我们将捐赠这个，你知道，以防止人们患上可怕的疾病等等。这确实引起了非政府组织社区、政府社区的注意。它成为了，我不会说是一项极其有利可图的业务，但至少是一项可行的业务。我明白它也有显著的，你知道，公共关系利益，因为现在他们从事的不仅仅是赚钱，
but they were also in the business of saving lives in poor countries, and that had sort of brand benefits, if you will, that also indirectly helped the bottom line. Yes, well, and you know, if you're helping a government look after their people, they're gonna be much more willing to have a conversation with you about what other products you might introduce in their country. You say that Procter & Gamble took advantage of an inflection point because
他们还从事在贫困国家拯救生命的工作，这有某种品牌利益，如果你愿意的话，这也间接帮助了底线。是的，而且你知道，如果你在帮助政府照顾他们的人民，他们会更愿意与你讨论你可能在他们国家引入的其他产品。你说宝洁公司利用了一个转折点，因为
they fell in love with the problem rather than the solution. What do you mean by this, Rita? Well, I think when we innovate, right, we have a tendency to make up in our heads what the right solution is, right? So, if I've got a problem with elderly people not able to drive, then autonomous cars is the solution. But instead, what I find with successful entrepreneurs and innovators, they tend to carve out a problem space for themselves that could be open to multiple solutions.
他们爱上了问题而不是解决方案。丽塔，你这是什么意思？嗯，我认为当我们创新时，对吧，我们倾向于在脑子里编造什么是正确的解决方案，对吧？所以，如果老年人不能开车，那么自动驾驶汽车就是解决方案。但相反，我发现成功的企业家和创新者，他们倾向于为自己开辟一个可以开放给多种解决方案的问题空间。
And I think we often forget that. There's lots of ways of making something happen that don't necessarily involve a whiz-bang technology or whatever. And in fact, in many cases, you're better off not having that. I'm wondering how much of the science of inflection points that you have studied at an organizational level, Rita, how much of this applies to individuals and their own lives? Are any of these lessons applicable to us as we navigate our personal lives?
我认为我们经常忘记这一点。有很多方法可以实现某件事，而不一定涉及炫目的技术或其他什么。事实上，在许多情况下，你最好不要拥有那种技术。丽塔，我想知道你在组织层面研究的转折点科学，有多少适用于个人及其生活？当我们处理个人生活时，这些教训中有哪些是适用的吗？
Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. I think, you know, so much of the human journey, we don't like to think about this, but a lot of it is serendipity and chance and did the right person speak up for you at the right time and did you happen to live in the right zip code you know a lot of what we end up doing in life has that flavor to it and so I think the inflection points really come when you know big moments like you go off to school and there's a whole new group of people that you meet or your family moves and there's another social setting that you're in or you lose a job and it turns out maybe that wasn't such a bad thing or or you get a job and who expected that and you proved to be really good at it so I think in personal
哦，绝对，绝对。我认为，你知道，人类旅程的很大一部分，我们不喜欢考虑这一点，但其中很多是机缘巧合，是否有人在正确的时间为你说话，你是否恰好住在正确的邮政编码区，你知道，我们最终在生活中所做的很多事情都有那种味道。所以我认为转折点确实出现在你知道重大时刻的时候，比如你去上学，遇到了一群全新的人，或者你的家庭搬迁，你处于另一个社交环境中，或者你失去了一份工作，结果发现那可能并不是一件坏事，或者你得到了一份工作，谁能想到呢，而且你证明自己真的很擅长它。所以我认为在个人
life we have the opportunity to really think about inflection points you want to think about these things as what I'll call options an option is a relatively small investment you're making today that buys you the right but not the obligation to make a bigger investment in the future. And we do this in real life all the time, right? So we go to school, we invest in a skill building course, we agree to go to a training program. We do these things not that we know exactly what what's gonna happen, but we think it'll create opportunities in the future.
生活中，我们有机会真正思考转折点。你想把这些事情看作我所说的“期权”，期权是你今天进行的一项相对较小的投资，它为你购买了权利，但不是义务，在未来进行更大的投资。我们在现实生活中一直这样做，对吧？所以我们去上学，我们投资于技能培养课程，我们同意参加培训计划。我们做这些事情并不是因为我们确切地知道会发生什么，但我们认为它会在未来创造机会。
So I think what you wanna think to yourself is, is the cost of this, and I mean cost just in terms of effort and emotion and exhausted and everything, is it got a big upside or a not so big upside? One thing that strikes me is that when it comes to running a business or running an organization, the metrics of success are relatively clear. So if you're a business, you know, you have happy employees, you have happy customers, you're making money,
所以我认为你想对自己说的是，这个的成本，我指的成本仅仅是努力、情感、精疲力竭等等，它有一个巨大的上升空间还是一个不太大的上升空间？有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是当经营企业或组织时，成功的指标相对清晰。所以如果你是一家企业，你知道，你有快乐的员工，你有快乐的客户，你在赚钱，
you're a successful business. It's very straightforward in some ways what constitutes a successful business. It's a little bit harder with individuals, I think. It's a little harder at an individual level to say what constitutes success. And I'm wondering, from that point of view, does that make the signs of inflection points a little more difficult at the personal level? Because it's not quite clear
你就是一家成功的企业。在某些方面，什么构成成功的企业是非常直接的。我认为对于个人来说，这有点难。在个人层面上说什么是成功有点难。我想知道，从这个角度来看，这是否使转折点的迹象在个人层面上更难识别？因为并不完全清楚
what actually constitutes success or failure. Some of that is subjective, some of that involves a personal sense of what matters to you, what doesn't matter to you. Do some of the things then fail to carry over because of the subjectivity, do you think? Well, I think when it comes to personal success, there's a bunch of really interesting research that's done about what makes people feel happy, what motivates people.
什么实际上构成成功或失败。其中一些是主观的，其中一些涉及个人对什么对你重要、什么对你不重要的感觉。你认为，由于主观性，有些事情是否无法延续？嗯，我认为当谈到个人成功时，有很多关于什么让人感到快乐、什么激励人们的研究。
And Dan Pink talks about you want a sense of agency in your life, you want to know that you have the right to make choices and have control. You want to gain a sense of mastery. And that could be many different things. For some people, mastery is woodworking, and then they go very happily to the rest of their formal job in an insurance company and fill out forms all day long, and that's fine with them. And then the last is a sense of purpose, a sense of motivation.
丹·平克谈到，你想要生活中的一种代理感，你想要知道你有权做出选择并拥有控制权。你想要获得一种掌控感。这可以是许多不同的事情。对有些人来说，掌控感是木工，然后他们非常快乐地去保险公司完成剩下的正式工作，整天填表，这对他们来说没问题。最后是一种目标感，一种动力感。
And I think a lot of research suggests that if you are in communities where you are of service to others and you feel that your life has a greater purpose, that you tend to be more satisfied with that life, you tend to find greater fulfillment in it. So when it comes to translating inflection points from the business world to the personal, I think one of the differences is that it's so much more associated with your values and what makes you feel that you've made a contribution and you're feeling fulfilled and you're doing well by other human beings. Rita McGrath studies the science of reinvention at Columbia Business School. She's the author of Seeing Around Corners, How to Spot Inflection Points in Business
我认为很多研究表明，如果你处于一个为他人服务的社区，并且你觉得你的生活有更大的目标，你往往会对那种生活更满意，你往往会在其中找到更大的成就感。所以当谈到将转折点从商业世界转化为个人世界时，我认为区别之一是它与你的价值观以及什么让你感到你做出了贡献、感到满足、并且你对其他人做得很好有更多的联系。丽塔·麦格拉思在哥伦比亚商学院研究重塑科学。她是《转角遇见未来：如何在商业转折点发生前发现它们》一书的作者。
Before They Happen. Rita McGrath, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was an absolute pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love Hidden Brain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus.
丽塔·麦格拉思，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。这绝对是一种荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑Plus》。
It's where you'll find episodes you won't hear anywhere else. Plus, you'll be doing your part to help cover the costs of the research, writing, and audio production that go into every episode of the show. You can try Hidden Brain Plus with a free 7-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都听不到的剧集。此外，你将尽自己的一份力量帮助支付每一集节目背后的研究、写作和音频制作成本。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 免费试用《隐藏的大脑Plus》7天。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。